well angel sometimes the the show just
didn't have enough soul alright another
list and revisit to something related to
the works of joss whedon we're gonna go
back to angel and I did my tops I gotta
do the bottoms what I feel at least to
my tastes are the 10 worst episodes of
Angel this list was hard to put together
for much same reason that the best of
angel list was hard to put together
which is that there there are so many
things that get drawn out over multiple
episodes often times there are plot
elements or aspects of characters who I
don't particularly like but they keep
showing up across episodes and they're
actually only a small part of any given
episode and I can't go like oh that's
the episode that's all about that thing
I don't like instead it's little bits in
episodes otherwise I do like so I
couldn't just trying to figure out
actual single episodes that I'm like
that was not good was a lot more work
than I thought it would be but this is a
list that I've got this is my 10 may not
be your 10 some people's favorite
episodes will probably be on there I
have a tendency to do that sometimes I'm
not doing it to just make you angry but
stick with me we'll get through this so
starting with number 10 the cautionary
tale of numero Cinco now looking at it
in a vacuum this is one that I see come
up on other people's lists sometimes but
I actually don't think it's that bad of
an episode in and of itself I do however
think that if they were gonna do
something like this it really should
have been done season 1 of season 2
instead it shows up in season 5 which is
the darkest and most dire season that's
not to say you couldn't do silly in
season 5 season fight gave a smile time
of all things but wear a smile time
feels like it flows and integrates and
plays off of the darkness that had come
before it the cautionary tale of numero
Cinco with its Lucha Libre wrestlers and
and campy nature feels more
at odds then smile time did and I can
only just chalk that up to to execution
and it just not quite fitting in its
placement in the show and sometimes that
is what happens sometimes an episode is
made better or made worse not because of
what it is but because when they choose
to have that story get told in the
overall framework of the show and I
think that is what really hurt this one
number 9 tomorrow this is the one that
in that includes Cordelia being taken up
by the powers that be now my feelings
about the stuff that went on with
Cordelia in later seasons 3 and then
later on a season 4 I'm kind of of two
minds about I actually don't think I I
don't have a ton of issues personally
with what happened to the with a lot of
things that happen with the character
that I know other people are really
upset by however I do at least so far as
I understand what went on behind the
scenes that caused a lot of those
writing decisions that's stuff I'm like
what but this whole thing with the and
this has specifically this this was one
where this is a store where where I'm
like a kind of iffy on it like sometimes
it works sometimes it does it but I can
encapsulate it into an episode and it's
this one and between Cordelia with this
revelation that you know I love angel
and but then you know being told you're
being called to a higher power and
literally ascending into effectively
into heaven it's weird in a bad way and
angel could be weird in very good ways
at times but it feels like something out
of another show if it feels like a very
special episode of something it's the
the way that things built up between
angel and Cordelia didn't feel organic
and then having it culminate in this
kind of moment and have it supposed to
ring as like us
a joyous thing with her going when it
just comes off as like wait what and
yeah it just doesn't work number eight
double or nothing I've just got five
words for this one soul sold for truck
[ __ ] so yeah this is the episode where
we find out that guns sold his soul for
a truck and I understand what it's
trying for I understand that it's trying
to be a story about consequences which
is actually a narrative and an element
that the show usually does very well and
it's trying to layer that with you know
the thing the stupid decisions we make
in our youth sort of filtered through
the mirror of the things that people do
when they think they don't have a future
because gun didn't see well he probably
didn't understand the value of his soul
but he also didn't think he was gonna be
alive for this to be collected before he
died anyway because he didn't expect to
live very long so there is potential and
the concept of this but he's only soul
for a truck and what actually comes out
of that and him having to answer for
that
isn't wrong for the kind of poignancy
that the show is usually able to milk
out of dealing with consequences it just
feels much more superficial and it feels
almost kind of patronizing like oh look
what this this guy did back when he was
a street kid who didn't know better it's
like well I feel like they took the
wrong angle for what they were trying to
do number seven I fault pieces so this
this is the episode about a guy who can
pull himself apart and his limbs or
various bits of him can act
independently and that's supposed to be
scary
no I'm sorry cuz a guy whose hand can
crawl like that can be a little creepy
but like in you know in the way that
boys something's we've something weirds
going on around here kind of creepy but
not in like I should be scared of this
guy because his hand can walk away that
no no that's like total b-movie
shoestring eighties slasher teen horror
premise and just uh it's laughable and
and it tries to weave uh a stalking and
domestic abuse kind of story with it
which i think is too heavy a story for
how goofy this monster-of-the-week
gimmick is and new number six the life
of the party this is the episode from
season five where Lauren gave up his
sleep and that starts impacting
everybody in weird ways Lorne is one of
those characters who is a brilliant
supporting character he has terrific
chemistry a great dynamic with a whole
bunch of characters he's a wonderful
element in so many episodes he doesn't
work when they when they devote episodes
to him specifically it he he is built
from the ground up has a supporting
player he's good at that let him do that
but yeah episodes focused more on him
they just kind of fall flat and this one
does too and we're again dealing with
that clash of tone that it's it's like
it's trying to lay the groundwork for
the consequences of what these guys are
doing in their positions that Wolfram &
Hart but again it's going
guffy with it when there are so many
other episodes that deal with
consequences with such poignancy and
this just doesn't it's just weird with I
think what's gonna was marking territory
and like there's a big monster version
of Lauren and like everything people
won't stop dancing it's the whole thing
is just strange and in a way that is not
intriguing number five
provider this is the episode with all
the concerns about how to make money to
care for the baby because this is after
Connor was born before he gets yanked
off to a hell dimension and shows up so
much older so this is the kind of
logistical nuts and bolts episode that I
feel like sometimes shows feel obligated
to do so that they can say they didn't
leave a plot hole but they didn't get an
interesting story out of covering up a
plot hole that I for one would have been
prepared to give them the benefit of the
doubt on like I understand that they
were kind of always strapped for cash
and that a baby as a time sink I've had
one and so I do understand that but you
know just a couple of token references
of you know we there are major repairs
on the hotel we're putting off so that
you know we can get diapers or one as
opposed to making it all about
know we're going to make all this extra
money and basing the actually basing the
episode around that and first of all it
turns Connor into into more of a plot
device than he already was and a prop
he's something to drive this this story
of this episode but he there it's not
the story of how they adjust to what it
means emotionally to advocate it's about
how do we pay for all this which is the
most superficial way to deal with
suddenly having a child in your life and
yeah that annoys me number four she
could probably be retitled a very
special angel episode this is again a
case of heart in the right place but bad
execution very misguided very
heavy-handed with its attempt at female
empowerment and its attempt to tackle
some you know a fantasy metaphorical
version of you know human trafficking
and and just demoralization of when
and it but it's just trying so on the
nose and so ham-fisted li that it at
least for me my brain kind of rejects it
like this is not a this is not a premise
or something that I'm initially gonna go
uh don't do something about that like no
do something about that you can get
something out of that but then it's just
beating you over the head with these
these women are equal like these demon
women yes I know re well I'm like yeah I
know that I know can like are we going
any deeper than that there's a lot more
to be mind and it's just so it's just
it's it's a very special episode that's
how it feels
number three one that I'm pretty sure
I've seen some people say they really
like but I don't the girl in question
the Buffy cameo but not really episode
so there's a couple of problems with
this first off I don't like Andrew who
shows up poured it over from Buffy I
don't like him I've never liked him
I came to dislike him slightly less as
time went on but I've never enjoyed him
as a presence so teasing me that we're
gonna get Buffy but only giving us him
and not only like teasing at the front
end and then he shows up and like oh no
Buffy's not coming like teasing the
whole episode all we see is the back of
the head of a stand and like come on
it's man it just it infuriated me at the
time and I look at it and it's and it's
such a superficial way to build up the
antagonism and play it up between spike
and Angel and again it's the cheap way
to go when I know this show can tackle
these kinds of things better smarter and
does that elsewhere in other episodes so
when they take the cheap route it just
annoys me all the more number two the
house always wins
it's a lauren episode again go figure
that this is the one where Lauren is
trapped at a casino basically under
contract and his his abilities being
used to steal people's destinies which
is an odd premise but again building the
so primarily around Lorin largely
doesn't work and kind of falls flat it
doesn't help that that's that you know
the bad guys are very cartoonish in this
the scheme is kind of ridiculous the
casino as a setting isn't that
interesting even though it looks like
they put a lot of effort into this sort
of new you know new place and look at
all this I'm like it's not it's not
interesting it's not interesting to
watch you didn't you know so the house
cheats at gambling Wow
really and it it's an episode that just
it's one of those times where it feels
like an episode that should have been a
Buffy episode it feels like the kind of
issue of the week sort of thing that
honestly worked better on Buffy Angel
was at its best when it was when it was
stringing out long-form emotionally
wrenching character arcs and drama when
it did you know problem of the week it's
when it tended to fall at its most flat
and I think this is an example of that
and that brings us to my personal least
favorite I'm not sure I can actively
argue that it isn't by any objective
measure the worst but I really don't
like it and ivory watched it I still
really don't like it and it and it
becomes an interesting thing works like
a miracle that I ended up sticking with
the show and loving it so much because
it's the very first episode of the show
city of I don't like this episode like I
don't like a lot of the first season at
all I think the first season is clunky
and doesn't know what it wants to be or
what it wants to be at this point is
very derivative and on isn't interesting
the show didn't really start to get good
beyond just my natural affinity for
these characters until the second season
and this first episode it just it's
awkward and it's clunky and it's generic
and it's yeah yeah it's to me it feels
like when I watched the first episode
I'm watching all the episodes that I
dislike boiled down into their
primordial form this
first episode just embodies all the
times that at least for me the show
misfired and misstepped and or just
failed to deliver much of anything
interesting because there isn't anything
really interesting going on in this it's
it's the most generic initial starting
set up kind of thing that you can
possibly come up with and I don't like
it at all so that's my list of what are
my 10 least favorite episodes of Angel
what is your list I'm sure it's much
different from mine and that's fine
whatever it is though drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do such as like
subscribe support me on patreon if
you're the generous type links for all
that stuff is down in the description
because there's way more than just that
if there's Twitter and t-shirts to buy
etcetera so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]